The Joe Rogan Experience you guys should
go and do some [__] Muay Thai let's
go I know yeah
oh no I I stopped a [__] chicken I
got a concussion and I stopped she's in
her software don't don't do concussions
she's a soft girl now Joe did you see
Mark Zuckerberg won a gold medal in a
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu competition
no Mark Zuckerberg is a [__] Savage
he's been training Jiu Jitsu this is
what he did he wore a covid mask and he
[__] put a hat on and he hid no
imagine you're right about to compete
and like maybe your first competition
ball just give it a try I mean what's
the worst thing that could happen worst
thing it happened gets strangled by a
super nerd
Zuckerberg so embarrassing I'm very
proud of him I think that's I think it's
amazing it's amazing that he did that a
few people have done that Mario Lopez
did that
um uh Bane
he could be listening to this I just
realized that it's awesome Hardy I'm not
gonna do that but you know what I mean
Tom Hardy you could DM me
I said yes DM me mommy
he was awesome Warrior like I bought it
I bought a hook line and sinker there's
certain dudes that can just be they
become different people like he was a
different person that Venom movie so you
believed he was that like sort of clumsy
character the Venom movie affected by an
alien he's [__] so just to pull that
off you know how hard it is to pull off
you're you're doing a movie with CGI
there's a CGI alien that comes out of
you a giant spider creature it's a
different place you have to go in your
mind at that point but he actually
pulled it off and he does it yeah it was
good see he's got look at that gold
medal wow wow dudes [__] jacked well
by the time you get to blue belt you're
dealing with people that know how to
submit people it's just whether or not
they can keep it together smoothly and
there's various levels of that and when
you get to tournaments you get like a
lot of the levels are like the guys who
really should be a purple belt they're
like they're really purple belt level
like some some instructors are stingy so
for him to win blue belt it's very
possible he had like real skilled
opposition you know not like black belt
opposition but they know how to do [__]
for sure look at Zuckerberg strangling
[__] actually that's pretty hot
Zuckerberg if you're listening
my DMs are open uh these nosy DMS are
okay just [__] read them he's in them
he doesn't even need the FBI he already
heard us he already heard us and this
doesn't aired
your [__] phone is lighting up every
time his name gets mentioned it goes
into a file
super I'm I think that's amazing I love
when people like just he doesn't have to
do anything he's one of the richest
people on Earth and he just takes a
chance and tries to get good at this
thing and then goes and competes in this
thing yeah we should all celebrate that
that's amazing but that's probably why
he's one of the richest guys on Earth
because he just goes for it commits he's
focused Instagram motivational speaker I
will I feel like what you just said
right there will stir Nations
he just goes for it he commits yeah
that's the thing you just got to be that
kind of person some people just that's
their big problem they don't know what
to go for right so they kind of get
stalled in the parking lot like which
direction where do I go because they
don't have me giving them motivational
speeches